>> Juan: FOX NEWS HAS CONFIRMED
THAT A 11th PERSON HAS DIED IN
THE DOMINICAN REPUBLIC.
THIS COMES AS HEALTH OFFICIALS
LASHED OUT AT RECENT REPORTS
EXPOSING THE DEATH OF A DOZEN
AMERICAN TOURISTS WHILE VISITING
THEIR COUNTRY.
OFFICIALS CALLING IT FAKE NEWS
AND HYSTERIA AIMED AT HURTING
THE COUNTRY'S TOURISM.
THE FBI IS ANALYZING ALCOHOL
SAMPLES FROM ONE HOTEL MINI BAR
TO SEE IF TAINTED BOOZE IS TO
BLAME FOR A STRING OF TOURIST
DEATHS.
SO GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS ARE
USING THE #BEFAIRTODR TO COMBAT
WHAT THEY CALL HYSTERIA.
YOU CAN ARGUE HOWEVER ONE LIFE
IS ONE LIFE TOO MANY.
TOURISM MAKES UP 17% OF THEIR
ECONOMY.
IT'S NOT LIKE IT'S 99.
HOW DO WE RESPOND TO THAT?
GREG?
>> Greg: I LIKE THAT.
THE D.R. NEEDS A D.R.
I DON'T THINK THE DOMINICAN
REPUBLIC WANTS -- THEY SHOULDN'T
BE THE MAYOR.
YOU WANT TO BE ROY SNYDER.
THE MEDIA CAN HELP BY SHINE AGO
SPOTLIGHT BUT THEY CAN HURT.
THE EARLY STAGES OF THIS, NOBODY
KNOWS WHAT'S GOING ON.
I SYMPATHIZE WITH THE DOMINICAN
REPUBLIC THAT IT'S NOT ALL
HYSTERIA BUT THERE'S SOME
HYSTERIA IN THIS FOG OF WAR.
EVERYBODY IS REARRANGING THE
WORDS TO DIFFERENT EQUATIONS
WITHOUT GETTING AT THE TRUTH.
I THINK "THE FIVE" SHOULD GO AND
DO ON LOCATION SHOW AT THE D.R.
>> Jesse: LIFT THE BOYCOTT.
>> Greg: YES.
JESSE HAS TO LIFT THE BOYCOTT.
>> Jesse: IF IT'S ALL EXPENSES
PAID, I'M IN.
>> Juan: BUT DON'T DRINK FROM
THE MINI BAR.
>> Emily: I GOT AN EAR
INFECTION.
>> Dana: THAT'S IT.
>> Greg: I SYMPATHIZE WITH THEM
BECAUSE A LOT OF STUFF IS NOT
TRUE.
BUT THERE'S SOMETHING THERE THAT
THEY HAVE TO SOLVE.
>> Juan: IT'S THEIR POSSIBILITY.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK THEY HAVE
BEEN TRANSPARENT OR CLEAR WITH
PEOPLE ABOUTING WHAT'S GOING ON.
WE ALL AGREE -- WE'VE SAID ON
THIS SHOW, IT'S A SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF VISITORS THAT GO TO THE
DOMINICAN REPUBLIC.
SO I DON'T THINK WE'VE BEEN
UNFAIR.
I'M NOT SPEAKING FOR JESSE.
BUT I DO THINK TO ME LIKE FOR
EXAMPLE, ON THIS DAVID ORTIZ
SHOOTING THING, NOW THEY'RE
SAYING IT'S NOT DAVID ORTIZ.
IT'S A ANOTHER TARGET.
ARE YOU COVERING SOMETHING UP?
IT'S LIKE MALAYSIA, THE MISSING
PLANE.
THE ANSWER IS WITH THE MALAYSIAN
GOVERNMENT.
THE DOMINICAN GOVERNMENT SHOULD
BE TO USE, YOUR ANALOGY, MORE
ROY SCHNEIDER AND NOT THE MAYOR.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
>> Jesse: I FINDS IT DISTASTEFUL
THAT THEY'RE USING THE PHRASE
FAKE NEWS.
WHERE DID THEY GET THAT FROM?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW.
>> Jesse: IRRESPONSIBLE.
SO I BELIEVE THIS IS A CARIBBEAN
INSIDE JOB, TOURISM TERRORISM.
SABOTAGE SOME WOULD SAY.
I LOOKED UP THE NUMBERS.
THE D.R. BRINGS IN 6.81 MILLION
INTERNATIONAL TOURISTS A YEAR.
THE NUMBER 1 TOURIST DESTINATION
IN THE CARIBBEAN.
SECOND, CUBA.
MAIN SUSPECTS.
HEAR ME OUT.
THE GUYS FROM THE AGENCY IN THE
D.R. SAY THIS.
A TOURISM ATAKATA.
THE P.R., PUERTO RICO, WAS JUST
HIT BY A STORM.
THEY'RE LOSING OUT ON TOURISM
DOLLARS.
SUSPECT NUMBER 1.
NUMBER 2, CUBA.
OBAMA OPENED UP THE ISLAND.
TRUMP CLOSED IT.
>> Greg: THANK YOU, OBAMA.
>> Jesse: THOSE ARE MY TWO MAIN
SUSPECTS.
KEEP THIS INVESTIGATION GOING.
>> Greg: OBAMA?
YOU LET OUT HAITI.
>> Juan: ARE YOU SERIOUS?
>> Jesse: JUAN, PEOPLE ARE
DYING.
>> Juan: YOU'RE SERIOUS.
>> Emily: DANA IN THE LIBRARY,
COLONEL MUSTARD CLEARLY.
>> Dana: WITH THE MINI BOTTLE OF
SCOTCH.
>> Jesse: JUST WAIT TILL THIS
PLAYS OUT.
>> Dana: I WOULD BE INTERESTED
IN THE P.R. FIRM.
I BET THEY'RE AMERICAN.
THAT WOULD BE FINE.
THIS IS AMERICAN JOBS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THE OTHER THING NOT ONLY IS THE
GOVERNMENT -- JUST TAKE A LITTLE
SEMBLANCE OF WE'LL CHECK IT OUT.
WE'LL CHECK IT OUT.
INSTEAD, IT'S LIKE -- AND YOU
HAD THE ONE BILLIONAIRE FROM
DOWN THERE SAYING IT'S ACTUALLY
AMERICANS THAT CANNOT HANDLE
ALCOHOL OR ALL YOU CAN EAT
BUFFETS.
>> Emily: DON'T TEST US.
>> Dana: THERE'S A RESPONSE
BESIDES WE'LL CHECK INTO IT AND
WE'RE SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS.
>> Greg: YOU'RE A LAWYER.
WHAT DO THE FAMILIES GET?
WHAT RIGHT DOS THEY HAVE?
IF MY RELATIVE DIED THERE, WHAT
CAN I DO?
>> Emily: IT DEPENDS.
THEY NEED THE INFORMATION --
>> Dana: THE FBI IS GETTING IT.
>> Emily: SO AFTER THAT, WE'LL
FIND OUT.